-Hello!
Hi, guys. Um,
have you seen any movies?
[ Laughter ]
Any movies?
Any of them?
Have you guys seen any movies?
-Yeah!
-Yeah? Which ones?
-"Aquaman."
-Okay. Okay.
I'm looking for
a specific movie.
[ Laughter ]
-"Bohemian Rhapsody."
-Mm, I'm looking for
"Mama Mia" two.
Has anyone seen it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh! Good!
I'm so -- The women, good.
It's a wonderful film. I'll get
to the jokes in a second.
I just want to make sure
everybody sees this movie.
It's a great film.
If you don't know the premise,
basically
they take all the ABBA songs
that didn't quite fit into
"Mama Mia" one,
and they sweep them up
into a little dustpan
and blow them [blows]
onto a Greek island,
and they really make Greece
look like it's doing all right.
It's wonderful.
Cher is in it. She's so good.
I mean, how great is Cher,
you know?
She's so great.
She's in a lot of group scenes,
but they're all single shots,
so it's possible they let her
shoot it from home.
Yeah. I guess I should say
kind of close to the top,
I do have a very specific voice.
A lot of people say it sounds
like I'm about to cry.
But I just want to let you know,
I'm not about to cry.
I'm actually about to laugh.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
It's nice you guys
are all out here.
Are you guys night people?
[ Audience cheering ]
Got some night people.
You can always tell
the night people
'cause they're like,
"What are we doing after this?"
It's like, can you imagine?
Sounds so terrible --
the reward for going here
is you get to go home.
And I thought I was maybe
a morning person
'cause of how much
I hate the night,
but then I got a job,
and it turns out
I'm not supposed to wake up.
And I was kind of bummed,
'cause I was like,
"Maybe I don't have a time,"
you know?
But I recently found my time.
I am the "hour before lunch"
person.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, thank you. Thanks.
Maybe you guys are, as well.
Yeah. That's when
I'm really excited,
I'm really curious, you know,
because lunch can be anything.
You know? Like, Tariq,
can I ask you what you had
for lunch today?
-Yeah. Onions.
-What is that? What?
[ Laughter ]
-Onions -- it's a --
I guess it's a vegetable.
-Lunch can be anything.
You know?
I get so excited
about the possibilities,
but you know I'm always
gonna get soup.
[ Laughter ]
And soup sucks.
It's either too hot
or it's just wet.
[ Laughter ]
You take the first bite of soup,
you better like it
'cause that's all the rest
of the bites.
You know?
If you get a different bite,
something's messed up
with the soup.
That joke was for
the soup haters.
This next one's
much more universal.
Here we go.
You know this situation,
you know what I'm talking about.
You know what I'm saying,
You know -- you --
You're at home.
Everybody knows it.
You know what I'm talking about?
You're at home.
You know what I mean?
And you're sitting down.
You know what I'm talking about?
When you're sitting down
and you're at home?
You know what I mean?
And you're opening
your Russian nesting dolls?
You know what I mean?
And they're getting
smaller and smaller?
You know what I'm saying?
And you ever get to
the tinniest one
and you think, "Hey,
this should be edible"?
[ Laughter ]
Just a little crunchy something,
no big deal.
You go to your friend's house,
you're like, "Did you
eat yours?"
"Yes. You?"
"Yeah, yeah."
I have a problem
with online shopping.
And I worry that
my online shopping habits
will, like, kind of start going
into real-store behavior,
like I'll just start breaking
into stores at 1:00 A.M.,
putting nine things in a cart,
and leaving.
[ Laughter ]
But I really like
online shopping
'cause the reviews, I think
they're really helpful,
and they're also
pretty indicative
of the political climate.
You know?
Like, I was on the L.L. Bean
website recently,
and you know L.L. Bean is where
coats go to church.
And I was reading
this scathing review
this woman left about a coat.
It was horrible. She was like,
"The wind sneaks up the back.
The zipper never works.
And the material is loud.
One star."
And I can't help but wonder if
she had written the same review
when Obama was President.
It would have just been like,
"Coat's not great, but it gives
me hope for a better coat."
All right, that's my time.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is...
Yeah!
...Jo Firestone!
For more, go to jofirestone.com.